the Joe Rogan experience dude I'm on a
full course Joe likes to be trendy and
Joe no it's not Joe down jozek an
extremist no there's a bunch of these
but I did it for an experiment mutters
out in his middle my new counter I
didn't count hey I wanted anyone here in
Aztec death sure I think you got a cup
it sucked on a date sucked on it count
such it would the Aztecs when they were
taunting the enemy they would do that on
the hillside like while they were camped
out sleeping that would keep them up all
night and psychologically [ __ ] with them
Jesus Christ I'm blowing that death
whistle no deaths coming he's already an
expert just gonna do it for us
you think those some Indians are like
dude maybe that's not a good idea let's
sneak up on them no man the games they
would stay on the outside edges
especially in the old bow and arrow days
you could [ __ ] with people because they
can only hit you so far away is he
blowing the Nasdaq whistle you're a
Honda yo
sounds like a demon let us try kissing
titties they say that oh dude that is me
that's [ __ ] dude if now imagine a
thousand half-naked warriors that are
definitely going to kill you and they're
screaming a from the hillside hopefully
love titties like that guy this is bad
no no no we're the Warriors okay you
gonna conjure a demon this is gonna blow
out your [ __ ]
this is like one of those you know it's
a bad idea
evil that was scary man all right well
they would do that to scare the [ __ ] out
of their enemy Jesus dude hard times
hard times made hard men dumped dumped I
had no energy coming here and now I get
here and I have so much in I know the
team's saying this is called Braille
energetic energy as we get older we
cherish this the fun times are like the
best times everything else is on sense
it's a family and fun time you don't
waste time
yeah but then there's like stuff you
have to do that's not fun but ensures
that the fun times will continue yeah
true like discipline exercise work you
got it you got to put in the time you go
to hustle if you don't hustle you're not
gonna enjoy the fun time juice juice day
its tranquility and excitement yeah like
how we are right now like having fun you
really can only do this correctly if
you're not worried about some [ __ ] like
if you have some other stuff that you
should be handling but you're not you're
blowing some things off yep
you know your your daughter as a recital
or some [ __ ] you know you're supposed to
be there you want to hang with your boys
that'll [ __ ] with ya
[Applause]